so yeah this is a wonderful we have a
strong in my group strong interest in
the interacts between environment and
health and this certainly includes
genome engineering of agricultural
species this is my conflict of interest
slide it you don't it take it take it
it's on our website if you want to get
into details but it it takes more than a
village to sometimes to achieve change
we have this design build test loop
where and we have a we benefit from a
huge exponential change in some of these
technologies and we also have to as a
consequence to be very cautious about
what we aim these technologies at and by
exponential I mean faster than any
exponential we've ever seen in any
technology including the the quite
breathtaking exponential for computers
and electronics even on that fast
exponential it should have taken a six
decades to get from three billion dollar
human genome to where we are today which
is around eight hundred dollars and it
continues to plunge and and this is one
of the things that my lab does is
focuses on reducing costs making it
accessible to people all over the world
and improving safety and quality so this
this law whatever it is is really more
of an observation we are developing in
particular these are these genomic
abilities so that we can do real-time
monitoring as say maybe even 24-7
monitoring of ourselves in our
environments we have instances where the
earlier that you detect an outbreak of a
minus or an old pathogen especially
foodborne ones such as in these cases
here the faster that you can nip it in
the bud and anticipate potential changes
so an example of a technology which is
not yet a 24-7 technology that everybody
has alongside their cell phone but is
getting very close is this so-called
nanopore technology that is one of the
lowest of our otherwise brief
breathtaking technologies is something
that I started working on in 1988
actually right here and but it now is
handheld it's based on these little
chips that can detect DNA as it goes
past these nanomachines polymerase and
pours the details are not for today but
the point is you might be able to
monitor the the pathogens allergens
composition your food and so forth as
good as our food labeling is I would
argue it could be a much better and this
would might be part of that that
solution it is definitely the case that
our interaction with food is not the one
size fits all that we often get from
large studies it is highly
individualized one so in addition to
technology for reading our environment
and our genomes and a genomes in our
environment we have the ability to
change it we have changed our own
genetic destiny there are now two
thousand gene therapies in two and three
clinical trials where people are
changing their own genomes but this this
is just a documentation of possibly the
most specific of all therapies ever
which is sometimes called Chris Berg
sometimes called the crisper craze it's
the class of nucleases that where RNA
finds its way to DNA with protein as a
mediator and this can be made
extraordinarily specific it's just
specific to about one part in ten to the
fifteenth base pairs so far and it's
getting better by methods such disease
we can use this not only to change human
beings as is already happening in other
gene therapies but to change our
environment what we eat there are many
things that are already being done by
combinations of classical and so-called
genetic modifications which I think in
the end result in the same kind of DNA
in these organisms just some are easier
than others and some of these are
response to
environmental changes like heat and
drought tolerance some of all of them
need to be inspected for safety and
efficacy over short and long periods of
time and some of some of them are
opportunities to deal with natural risks
we not only create human risks but we
have plenty of natural ones there are
synthetic end and natural pesticides
their pet that's the size pleasant plant
some of those are also carcinogens many
of them and there's a many opportunities
for improving this in our meat we have
things that many people have strong
reactions to not everyone and there are
cases where it can become a normal
animal can become spontaneously turn
into one that produces infectious
disease like a prime these are deletable
so both of these genes have been deleted
for various animals and without
consequence to the animal but with great
safety increase and then finally we have
this issue of pests and these can be
animal pests they can be vectors for
disease they can be invasive species
that interfere with agriculture or with
other quality of life issues and so
we've been exploring gene drives and
this is one illustrated intended for
reducing malaria but they're other ones
for other pests or vectors and the a
basic idea is that it's a it's a
synthetic selfish DNA that doesn't just
hop all over e where it randomly it goes
to a specific place and every time to
insects or other pests breed all of the
offspring get the selfish DNA which in
this case is also not just selfish but
it's delivering something that humans
find highly desirable like resistant
similary assaut the mosquito becomes
resistant malaria and the and then it is
not transmitted to humans and malaria is
like smallpox in that if we ever
eliminate it once it's eliminated
forever because humans are the only
resource the only natural reservoir for
that species and this can be generalized
to a variety of other invasive species
and pests reducing our our need for
pesticides and herbicides and so on we
have a cohort which is amazing the
cohort where we can test the interaction
genes of armors and traits and look at
personalization of foods drugs and other
things that impact our quality of life
this is the world's only open door
access data states and and there and
they've been available for years and I
urge you to take a look at them just
search for personal genome project or
get and then we have experiments on the
environment as well